he's Jeff Van Gundy back on the show how
are you Jeff good reg what's going on
I'm just taking this all in I wonder
what you think the story is so far the
first week and a half for the NBA
playoffs Jeff well I thought Brooklyn
and Orlando winning game ones on the
road was a huge accomplishment I think
both Philly and Toronto will win the
series but I thought that gave some
credence or some excitement to the first
round in the East that wasn't going to
be there I didn't think with because I
just thought there was such separation
between the top four and the bottom four
so those two wins I thought were good
and then you've got the Blazers taking a
200 lead into OKC tonight what do you
think's going through the temples of the
Thunder prior to this evening's game
Jeff well it's been their biggest
weakness for quite some time if they
just don't have offensive firepower they
don't shoot the three well and they
don't have bench firepower power other
than shrewder so they're a very limited
roster from an offensive standpoint and
that's why Westbrook George intruder all
have to play well for them high quality
teams particularly on the road so they
put a good first game got blown out in
Game two in the second half lower than
McCollum were terrific as was the whole
play blazer team I'm not sure exactly
why we're startled by that
maybe it's because they've got they had
gotten swept the two previous years but
Portland's a good team and they've been
consistent throughout the season and the
Warriors just dismantling Los Angeles
last night after being shocked by
blowing that 31 point lead do you think
the Warriors are still without a doubt
the unbeatable team in the West and if
not then who do you think's got the best
shot to take care of them I think
they're the best team I don't think
they're unbeatable though I think
Houston has played really well for a
long period of time I think they had a
good shot of them last year with home
advantage unfortunately Chris Paul got
hurt they were up double digits in game
both six and seven at half and give the
Warriors credit for coming back so I
think even though they don't have home
court this year the Rockets I believe
will push and are the only team in the
Western Conference that I'll be able to
push Golden State but I do think the
Eastern Conference champion whoever it
turns out to be but particularly if it's
Milwaukee or Toronto they would have a
they would have a puncher's chance to
win why is that well I just think both
teams you know you look at Milwaukee for
whatever reason people focus just on
Yanis but not on their whole team
they've been an elite offensive team top
five and an elite defensive team top
five that's the profile of a
championship caliber team the one thing
right now that they're battling is
injury I think Brogdon snell those
injuries are significant if they can get
back get into rhythm get healthy I think
Milwaukee is a really really good team
Jeff Van Gundy here on the Rich Eisen
show do you think Durant's made his mind
up do you think it's a done deal as it's
been discussed that he's going to go to
New York and try and build a franchise
winner in a city that you know is so
desperate for one Jeff I think most free
agents have a feeling of what they're
gonna do throughout the course of a
season but I think circumstances can
change those feelings so just because
the player feels like on April 17th or
18th what they're gonna do does that
mean they're gonna stick with that I
don't what I don't believe as people
don't think aren't thinking about it you
know the players themselves or they you
know they say they haven't given it any
thought I've never thought that to be
truthful so I think they do have hands
they have ideas but I think circumstance
can change and frankly if Golden State
wins it again I don't know if that gives
them a better chance or a worse chance
to retain
durán I'm not sure until you know a
person's priorities it's really hard to
know what they're gonna do because you
really don't know what means the most of
them it just seems to me Jeff and I said
this at the beginning of the show here
today that after a night like last night
that you look at the lawyers and Durant
and you say that Durant is still an
outsider because he joined the team
after they'd already won their first one
and he needs to go somewhere else in
order to build his own legacy and he
wants to do that despite clearly being
on a remarkable squad why would he want
to leave the situation that we saw
unfold last night Jeff I don't get it
yeah if he does I probably won't get it
either but again it doesn't matter what
we get it matters what the player
beliefs and what the player wants you
know frankly I was shocked at LeBron
James left Cleveland the first time I
was shocked he left Miami the first time
I thought I was shocked you left
Cleveland the second time so you know
again because you don't know what their
priorities are you don't you can't
figure out what they want to do and I
think certainly the one thing I disagree
with most media I don't think Duran had
to leave Oklahoma City to cement his
greatness as a player or a championship
mentality I always thought he went about
his business correctly he played hard he
played well but he did leave I don't
think of him any differently with the
Warriors as I did in Golden State or in
Oklahoma City
I don't think him as a greater player
there in Golden State just because he
joined a great team and wanted
championship or two and I won't think
any less of him as a player if he leaves
and goes to some other place that
doesn't mean I'll understand it
necessarily but I won't think of him any
lesser Jeff Van Gundy here on the Rich
Eisen show speaking of shocking you
certainly caught my ear a few weeks ago
Jeff when you said during a game that if
you're the Lakers you have to consider
trading LeBron Jay
is the way to try and figure out this
roster and how best to move forward do
you still feel that way don't you just
hate when what you say goes on record
terrible we all heard it Wow actually I
would never bet back away because I
listen in my time Shaquille O'Neal's
been traded Kareem abdul-jabbar has been
traded two of the greatest to ever of
played and so the idea that you would
never trade a great player
III think is naive and I think listen it
would be best if you could build a
championship team around James if you
could assure yourself that you're gonna
get an Anthony Davis type or two to join
up but if that doesn't pan out and you
have to try to build a championship
caliber team on a different timeline
meaning you don't think you're gonna get
there during James's time in LA then you
have to think about everything's got to
be on the trick table you've not been in
the playoffs six straight years and you
have every advantage in the NBA you have
whether you have money you you have
everything and you haven't been there
for six years so you have to think
outside the box now they did a great job
in getting James there
Magic Johnson Rob palinka did a great
job of convincing him to come there but
that doesn't mean that you don't have to
continually to think about what's best
for your team and I would say probably
99.9% they're going to keep them but I
could see if they got a Herschel Walker
Minnesota Vikings type deal or Paul
Pierce Kevin Durant Brooklyn Nets deal
that you would seriously have to
consider it well if if if GE bus reached
out to you in the in the aftermath of
Magic Johnson essentially just tapping
out out of nowhere and tyloo is now
coming in for an interview and obviously
it's some that's somebody that you're
you'd be I don't know if the word
catering would be because he does have
some Lakers history but obviously LeBron
James knows him and is very comfortable
with him what advice would you give the
owner of the Lakers right now with July
1st around the corner and being such a
crucial period for that franchise don't
listen to that idiot man gonna look at I
lose that I think if they decide to go
that way the two guys that they're
considering it seems tyloo and Monty
Williams are both eminently qualified
and have history with James I think
their roster last year now listen I want
to get them the benefit of the doubt to
when James exited on Christmas Day in
the third quarter of that game they won
at Golden State and they were in fourth
place he was out longer than everybody
anticipated they sort of cratered during
that time and I think what no one no one
thought was when he came back that they
would still be bad and so I don't think
you can overreact but I think the roster
around him last year because they made
him up of one-year contract guys made
very little sense as far as how the fit
was around James and how he's proven to
be at his best offensively now I do
think James and the rest of the team but
particular games to get to championship
caliber in a highly competitive Western
Conference he's going to have to put up
the same numbers and he's gonna have to
recommit defensively and that doesn't
mean 48 minutes of defense for 82 games
that means like most great scorers pick
time and places that you absolutely turn
it on defensively when it's crunch time
of games because he's no longer I mean
he looks unbelievable he still plays
great but he's not young he has a lot of
wear and tear on him and he can't be you
know 48 minutes of all-out defense but
he can be
more attentive sensibly and I think
within that area last year well Jeff as
you know I your opinion that's why I
love having you on as much as we have
you on and I hear what you say during
the games by I pay close attention so I
think you are aware that we did notice
last NBA Finals I don't think we've had
you on since then that we noticed you
mentioned on the air that your
classmates with Jodie Foster at Yale and
I see and then you cheap shot at me
after well I don't know I don't like she
tried her on and and just well same
total indifference to my existence in
the world well Jeff again I I we do have
we do we just needed clarification she
was not on for that specifically she was
promoting her film work but I do have
that I do just to be fair and balanced
want to give you the opportunity this is
this is how it went down last summer
well you went to Yale okay I don't know
if you're aware but you going to Yale
was brought up on Game two of the NBA
Finals no way yes Jeff Van Gundy who was
on the broadcast said he went to school
with you no way in a class sorry Jeff
don't remember you remember Jeff Van
Gundy can we bring up a picture of Jeff
Van Gundy the one in the middle is Jeff
Van Gundy does that stir does that ring
a bell rings no well whatsoever so did i
cheap shot you there Jeff I mean you
know you know what the crazy part is and
stop me if I've told you this story go
for it but so our freshman year there
was 12 guys on the floor and we had some
like Brainiac students and then we had
some misfits that didn't belong there
like myself and so we all threw in a
hundred dollars and said hey the first
guy that gets a date with Jodie Foster
you win the money
alright so 1,200 bucks Wow so I'm coming
back from the gym in the early fall and
there's a candy shop right
outside the big quad for freshmen and
all these sirens are going by and so I
stopped right in front of the candy
store and watch the sirens go by the
popcorn is popping it smells great and
from behind me someone goes man that
popcorn smells good and I turn around
and I'm gonna say yeah it does and it's
her and I totally choked and I think
yeah yeah and I run to my dorm so if he
doesn't remember me it's because I blew
my one chance at the money but to meet
thing right there yeah well if I'd known
that she might have remembered the famed
popcorn incident on the campus I don't
think so
ya know you know when yeah I think but I
did have my one chance of actually
meeting her I was in a class with her
and I mean first of all [ __ ] what a star
like actress where she said like she was
a star student there too I mean think
about it like who's in the class whether
we have to send the other side when all
the threats were you know the
assassination attempt against Reagan
right yeah I mean so what a time it but
she always handled herself so great well
what I chose like a guy who air-balled
the two free throws to win the game
sounds like you didn't even take your
shot Jeff that's what it sounds like you
just did look good well we we we figured
it was amazing you said it on the air in
like literally it she was scheduled to
be in studio a couple days later we
figured we'd ask and we did and now
we're bringing out you again turned out
great
now if I ever see her she was at a Laker
game like three years ago yeah three or
four years ago that we were doing she
was about six rows from me and I think
she was with family but the next time if
she comes to a Laker game or a soccer
game and I'm there I'm gonna go
introduce myself and she could you and
you could say I'm Jeff Van Gundy I'm the
guy from Yale
that rich brought up to you let's you
know just yeah I was totally not
memorable no I don't remember but you
said totally not memorable Jeff you're
the best man thanks for the call
appreciate it the 40 I got it look for
your forward to your call tonight on
ESPN and then on ABC later on this
weekend for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app